un début de saison parfait pour montigny
le bretonneux les cougars promu cette
année en 1re division longtemps porté ce
dimanche 2 avril sur la fin contre les
arvernes de carn ferrand le score 6-0
dans le premier match et 3 2 dans le
second
excellente très bonne journée c'était le
but c'était d'entrée de réussir notre
entrée dans ce championnat et on l'a
fait on a fait de très belle façon
on l'a fait avec des lanceurs qui ont
tout donné qui ont fait vraiment le job
sur le monticule
c'est ce que j'attendais c'est ce que
j'attendais aujourd'hui vraiment de
cette journée et voilà ça c'est ça s'est
réalisé ça et cécile c'est génial on
était tous motivés tous dans le dans
l'esprit d'équipé oui c'est tous motivés
on est tous solidaires c'est ce qui a
fait qu'on a qu'on a pu gagner avec ces
deux victoires les cougars de montigny
le bretonneux se retrouve en tête de
première division avec 100% de victoires
les objectif pourrait être revu à la
hausse les objectifs bah voilà ils sont
ils sont ils sont ce qu'ils sont c'est
allez allez prendre le alley semaine se
classer dans le haut de tableau
on a parlé de maintien on a parlé de 5e
6e place je pense qu'aujourd'hui on peut
on peut aller grimper on peut on peut
monter se placer en haut de tableau on
peut aller faire les play-offs
allez comme je dis chatouiller les
grosses écuries et les grosses équipes
qui sont là depuis des années on peut le
faire on peut vraiment le faire le
prochain match va arriver vite les
cougars se déplaceront ce dimanche 9
avril sur le terrain de rouen baseball
76 l'équipe qui a soulevé dix titres de
champion de france dans son histoire et
qui a remporté ses deux premiers matches
lors de cette première journée